[Music]
in boner kill news Oh
boner pills submitted by Bart is a DILF
oh that sounds like a pickle
I always forget I forget that - for some
reason I remember your mom but I forget
he's a dad yeah same same she no we know
she's a mom we know she's a mom hey how
do you guys know that no either we know
you're home what is that where's the
weak no wait what does that mean bro
yeah we're trying to say yeah what are
you trying to say I just identified well
you like moms yeah you want to make me
cry right no I know I love moms Geo when
jeans holding tyka it looks like hers
but then when what you did you made her
cry no she got the hair doesn't matter
she got the hiccups she's fine it was a
good try though when Bart holds tyka it
seems like he's borrowing Gio's baby
Tyco looks extra asian and then when I
hold them that I look extra asian Oh
Myka looks like G oh yeah I think TECA
looks like Bart is hell in the blind man
yeah at the beginning and then Gio took
over yes because Thai cos head isn't
square anymore it's a circle because it
used to be square yeah that's when you
were like that's clearly his dad uh-huh
no but he just has like Gio's highbrows
yeah inside yeah I'm less acute like
especially when he's like I see Bart
studying something and he does the
eyebrow see
no I see Gio in there but I think he
looks a part as hell you're wrong he
looks like me Oh Dan's penis excuse me
what's fractured after his child jumped
on him to wake him up
Oh morning how you get how do you
fracture there's no bone in there you
know what's [ __ ] out know what's a -
you know what - this way I think this
morning or last morn yesterday morning I
had morning wood and then I pick up
Tiger so that she can keep sleeping
because he wakes up at 5:30 so I went
downstairs I had to pee and I was hold
him like this and I had more you held it
while you're peeing
yeah but is this for his own safety I
hold them while I'm peeing with my
morning wood mm-hmm and he gets excited
starts going like this and he starts
kicking my dick spray in the side of the
toilet like this pretty funny ever sleep
in jail is wrong with you as a person
he's so big though that is [ __ ] foot
reaches your dick I don't know what he's
gonna do why don't you sit down and put
your [ __ ] down yeah and then close the
door so yeah you're holding it I do that
every morning and it's just so I have it
at this one I had morning woods just
kicking a [ __ ] kick to the side loses
foot wet no it kicked the bottom base of
the shaft great see why you guys see him
as much my kid that he occasionally
borrowed these are dad stories all of
you guys I go through this kind of stuff
it's just it's just my kid kicked my
dick kid freakin fractured the dad's
dick kid jumped on it yeah that's the
universe is jumping and he can't eject
I used to jump all over your dad and
uncles laps and [ __ ] they would always
be like stop getting good this is
getting him
because I was aiming to stop on a day
you're evil
Wow how old are you you know all boys go
through a stage of like wanting a kick
and punch dick because they know it
hurts yeah well that's very true much
yeah yeah we definitely know that that's
very I was like yeah maybe I don't know
I was a kid I was like on the playground
you ever grab that kid by the back of
the neck and then Nia's balls
that was pretty crazy you another kid or
is you right now no no I as another kid
yeah yeah yeah I remember I used to
threaten like give it back or I'll kick
you in the nuts like the worst thing you
could tell a boy yeah nuts such a mean
lady this guy stole my stuff he's a 36
year old who took viagra
oh [ __ ] so he went to sleep with a boner
so he tried to vigorously masturbate to
make it go away but it didn't work so he
decided to go to sleep hoping that the
erection will go away by the time he
would wake up in the morning yeah but
then add - you went to sleep his child
came in to wake him up and got his
jumped on top of him oh [ __ ] so he ended
up fracturing his penis and how that
happened was you know that sponge like
tissue that's in the tort corpus
callosum you saw the blanket like tp'ing
then he's all like oh yeah Joe does that
work at Joe can't Joe heat like with
your foot like if your foot moves in the
morning you'd like to [ __ ] with it so
like it's like a sandcastle that kids
want kids want to smash yeah but it's
like a dick under them yeah he's like
big paws yeah it ended up tearing it so
he had to have surgery to repair it Wow
that's about tear no I don't know how
many more kids you can make now oh it
took six weeks it still works
an erection erection again it was scary
and he didn't get to macerate the night
before for he trophy sex we just stayed
up we just stayed up he tried to
masturbate to make it go away it didn't
go and he came but it didn't go in my
dude that's good and the kid was like
happy morning time and then [ __ ]
jumped on his dick exactly did he tell
the police that he heard the doctor that
he tried to quote vigorously masturbate
the words that they're using in his I
think at that point I did try to bicker
same as the interviewer was like he's
like yeah and then I masturbated he's
like how hard yeah hard did you really
try to really try
I was vigorously don't worry I was
figured like that the doctor was like
hey news people you'll never believe
what I just heard today yeah how does
this [ __ ] get out of the hospital
yeah isn't there supposed to be like
some patient confidentiality [ __ ] or
maybe some I think it's okay to share as
long as you don't share indeed the main
like pin in the mouth doctor not gonna
tell anybody about this no no no no oh
absolutely
Oh India you might have they love
gossipy over there but we but we get
these stories here too that's what I
understand
oh yeah I mean social media people
people yeah Indians take viagra did he
say - correct yeah he took a hundred
milligrams oh oh marecus a pill popping
country beyond but a lot of other
countries aren't so like we're gonna pop
in it they probably you thought they
would have like Chinese style stuff like
[ __ ] Tiger dick or something maybe
has dick problem dick pills is universal
that's true curry powder viagra some
cultures are like oh rhino tusks round
up for you know yeah for elephant tusks
no black guy in the 40 old virgin
yep Romany Malco he's pretty guy he told
me that they Craig Robinson okay
no no Romany Malco who's that black guy
in the 40 old virgin oh yeah yeah he's
funny I used to write with him he told
me that he used to sell dick pills and
he made the most money like until I
became an actor like he was doing that
and he made the most money in his life
doing that [ __ ] like like until he
became an actor oh yeah yeah that was
funny he's funny as [ __ ] dude he's so
funny he's handsome why's he look like a
cleaner Charles Barkley oh that's the
guy that you're talking with yeah oh oh
you're thinking about well-dressed dude
yeah you're jealous
no he's very well just two very handsome
man very nice man anyway does he have
other kids I don't know they were just
mentioned that one kid and then they
just mentioned that he was complaining
of a deformed penis and a lot of
swelling and a
do that kids in the doghouse forever
yeah you're not the favorite kid ever
again
I just pictured like another kick coming
down and kicking his balls too
every time yeah baby you kick it to be
straight again oh yeah it cooks it back
yeah the users dig like it's a bouncy
house [ __ ] they stop like on it like
it's a trampoline oh I can't wait till
our kids uh run into our room and just
jump on our bed Oh kids ah yeah is there
a surprise happening soon I don't know
huh what a surprise no what about when
your kids are off to college in there
and you're laying in bed and they don't
run and jump in your bedroom I was gonna
be sad there where you have to get up
yeah begin our cars and then go to their
dorm and jump out of them yes there you
go well you could keep making kids till
you're like oh or if you just get a dog
no we just want you know you have a lot
of three yeah they have three maybe
three kids mainly two huh yeah do you're
not down for three yeah threes pretty
bad you I honestly would even be down
with one but it's just he'd be a lonely
dude be down for two with my body and
then maybe more with someone else's body
I'm cool with like no we won't we don't
believe in sorry you don't believe in I
see has to be natural birth or adoption
no way what Joe no I think it's awesome
when people get adopted and families
need you know people love and people
need families to love them that's
awesome for me you're kind of the but
I'm trying to get my genetics I already
have two kids that's what I'm saying
to from my money to spread those seats
all over the world where that is gonna
be even Brad Pitt couldn't hang with the
like I'm a good person I adopted thing
for very long you don't mean so you know
what they recently been reporting that
heat they're doing a custody battle and
that he might be getting all the kids
really because Angelina Jolie it's
[ __ ] up I don't know any nice headline
you haven't raised a kid collectors
what's really
no what's the spicy gas like okay so
he's like a vegan and she would like eat
steaks right in front of him be like in
life Oh Tim I'm like there were other
things like oh she didn't cry she didn't
like their biological children as much
because she said they were privileged
say that she said that I'm saying I'm
just giving you the tea that I heard
their kids because me saying a not a
privilege because of them yes she felt
okay this she adopted are now privileged
because she adopted right it's a
[ __ ] statement don't try to figure
it out this is the hot tea how many
biological kids they have together three
who are twins and then check I had no
idea and then how many adopted kids do
they have like science or some [ __ ] yeah
oh my god I only knew of two three or
four either three or four because
there's they were calling the Brady
Bunch level when it found they found out
about twins my god I just remembered
them the first one Maddox he was
sparking cute the Cambodian baby but now
he's probably like older than us he
outgrew us real quick oh yeah
accelerated aging that's like a
Dominican kid dude
oh yeah yes sprout up immediately dude
well six-year-old Dominican kid looks
like he's 2019 now no size one meme of
Saint you know Kim and Kanye's kid yeah
and it said cuz he looks like a big kid
now I got toddler and the caption says
she'll drink grow three to five business
days cuz we grew so fast but like that's
true just like Eminem's daughter Haley
yeah he's like 21 or something yeah yeah
well I just remembered like yesterday
where he was rapping about like a little
four-year-old burger my dad gone crazy
dude imagine being the guy that Haley
brings home tamanna yeah that would have
been awesome what until you find out
he's a psycho I can't believe it no but
then he my baby
yeah right my dad so can I call you
Marshall no shut the [ __ ] up you are
[Music]